[russian speech]
- There were many tense moments,
and according to state media,
hundreds of arrests
made in Moscow alone.
Our crew also getting caught
up in the pushing and shoving.
There's a massive
police presence on hand
here at these protests.
And time and again, we're
seeing scenes like this,
with the police pushing
and even making arrests.
OK.
[russian speech]
Russia's official news
agency put the turnout
at around 8,000 people at
the march in Moscow, declared
illegal by Russian authorities.
Taking to the streets to
criticize what they called
widespread corruption
among the country's elite,
the organizers say
similar gatherings
happened in about
100 towns and cities
across this vast country.
The man calling for
the action, opposition
activist and Kremlin
critic, Alexei Navalny,
was himself detained.
But those who followed
his call weren't
shy to voice their grievances.
- I'm against Putin.
Against his corruption.
- They can't support our
governments with their greed.
They steal out money
by using their power.
- These protests still
pose a serious threat
to Russia's president
Vladimir Putin, who boasts
approval ratings of around 80%.
But they showed
that the opposition
is willing to take
to the streets
whether the authorities
allow them to or not.
Fred Pleitgen, CNN Moscow.